hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of
wild ride with stevo this one
is great news for anybody who loves
music
and super cool people because we fell in
love with this guy
it's the lead singer of corn
legend and this is just good times
so here we go ladies and gentlemen
jonathan davis yeah i did
i'd like you to meet my co-host scott
randolph
what's going on off camera up at the
front of the rv
we have paul briskey what's going on
jonathan how are you
i'm just chilling man yeah dude i'm
super psyched that you agreed to do this
it was uh oh of course man
[ __ ] super cool are you in la right
now [ __ ] no i live in bakersfield
yeah dude born and raised
yes sir i hate l.a i can't take it no
more
ah dude i got out i got out like 10
years ago i just
i just i mean for some people it's great
it's just for me
i was born and raised here i like more
country stuff
so i just kick it out here with my
pickup truck and
i mean but bakersfield isn't really
really super hick but i like doing
redneck [ __ ] so it's nice out here
cool man um we have a mutual friend
in common big j okerson
yes i just talked to him yesterday i'm
nice
man i love that guy we took him out on
tour uh we did this tour
with uh the acremeister that was years
back
and he was he opened for us right so for
the people who don't know who big
jokerson is
he's uh a stand-up comedian yeah
an absolute master of crowd work he's
just the funniest guy
i've i performed with him very early in
my stand-up career
and i forget if it was like jokes that i
think he had a story about opening for
corn
and that like the picture he painted of
it was that
trying to do stand-up comedy for uh you
know in an arena for a rock and roll
band
as an opener it's like
it doesn't always work so like you're
doing stand-up in montreal at that
rock fest it was all right but it was
the best part of this act was
all the hecklers he would just tear them
new asses it was amazing
yeah how did you guys come up with the
idea to get big j
to open for you um it just came around i
mean they just asked if we would be down
for that i think it came with the
sponsors and all that and they said hey
we want to have this guy come out and do
comedy and we're like
that should okay i hope he's good he's
ready to get [ __ ] thrown at him
but he he really did great it wasn't
like that every night i'd go out and
watch him
my favorite part was when people would
talk [ __ ] he would just tear them
apart it was amazing yeah he's quick
with the crowd
crowd work he's super funny he's a good
guy
yeah dude so you were talking to him
just yesterday huh like
you talked to him frequently yeah we
kept in touch
over the years um when we play in new
york he comes out to our shows
and i just saw that someone tried just
body slammed him off the stage the other
night oh my god dude i
i thought that like oh he got knocked
out of pennsylvania then i saw the
footage like last night and dude it was
violent yeah it was violent that guy
that was because he was talking
[ __ ] someone was talking [ __ ] to him and
he was doing what he does and then just
some guy came up from behind and
and got him so i was like man you gotta
chill bro
this is some that's crazy coming up on
stage
i he says he's okay but man he took a
hard fall off that stage the guy just
that was [ __ ] up so he just like
checked him off the stage
oh he just grabbed him and took him off
the stage
yeah he was sitting on a stool the guy
grabbed his uh
feet and the stage was a good five feet
off the ground so the guy grabbed his
feet yanks him off the stool
and he comes forward all the way to the
ground in front of the stage and lands
like flat on his back which is
not healthy geez no jonathan have you
dealt with a lot of unruly crowds
yourself
yes sir yes sir that's what i have
that's why i have my boy sleepy he's
always looking out for me there you go
nice did you ever do the trick i forget
what they call it
but when you when you uh instruct the
crowd to
to split into two groups like down the
middle and then
they all run at each other all that wall
of death thing
yeah i i really we don't do that
yeah it's always been like the blacks
that's so straight like thrash
cool thing it's cool at metal shows and
it's amazing to watch but i've never had
the crowds do that right i like watching
that [ __ ]
i think the first time i saw that was at
papa roach
like i forget if i was doing a show with
papa roach but i just remember
like you know jacoby the the singer of
paparazzi is like
all right everybody's split up and then
on the count of three run into each
other and i'm thinking dude you can't do
that that's like a lawsuit yeah
that's like brave [ __ ] it's a real big
glass suit
it's so badass to see it though i've
watched it at festivals
in europe you know those humongous
crowds and you just see them just
bam and you just know someone's getting
jacked up yeah yeah that's insane
so you guys just put out a new corn
album last year
last year how long was it before that
um before that was two two years
two or three years um we always that was
our this
last record was our 13th record i mean
we're putting them out all the time
wow dude people are going crazy over
this last one
yes they really liked it and then he's
not cut short because all this copied
stuff happening but um we just started
to tour it but it's an
amazing record it was a hard record for
me to make but um
got through it i've always used music
and
my music to how i deal with things and
uh
yeah we got it i got it done it was good
it's not to say that they don't like all
your albums but i think that
just looking at this this new one
there's you know people are really
oh no this one's some some hit some
people get it
and then some people don't it just you
never know but this one people really
really liked what was so hard about
making this album just the experiences
that you went through
yeah well unfortunately my uh wife
died of an overdose so i had to go
through that
and it was hard yeah
and you know people addiction and mental
health issues
and all these things going on so um i
dealt with that
making that record uh was hard but you
know i got through it i'm i'm
good now everything's great i think good
i think that your music generally has
been pretty candid about
various trauma and difficulty in life
yeah i mean that's just that's how i
deal with this and unless i walk around
being depressed all the time
it's just that is how i deal with my the
things that go on in life and we all
have [ __ ] going in my life it never
stops um you know earlier records are a
lot me dealing with my childhood and
stuff but you know as
each record goes on you know [ __ ]
happens in life that's how i deal with
it
so um it's always been that that's some
people you know go to therapy or church
or whatever they want to do and it's all
good but for me
i got to just get it out with my art you
feel like once you make the song like
you kind of close that chapter
yeah for sure nice um yeah
so yeah there's we of course you know
that looked into uh
like the whatever did some research
yeah dude and dude my i think my
favorite thing
that we learned about you is uh working
in the coroner's office
yes sir i did that i started one of 17.
um i did it it was actually a there's
actually a class in high school it's
called rop
regional occupation program yeah so you
go in there and they had all this
they wanted to do some something in the
health industry you know
people went and became you know we're
doing
all kinds of stuff going in the hospital
and being assistants and helping do all
that stuff
and then the coroner's office came up
and i was like
i was just at that time i was so i've
always just been
i don't know something about dark stuff
has always grabbed me so i'm like
i wonder what's like to go cut up dead
bodies so
i went up i did three interviews to get
in they had to do a psych background
everything and i finally got in and i
started doing autopsies at 17. so i did
that
17-18 and then i went to frisco and went
to
the san francisco college of mortuary
science and became a mortician
came back here was an embalmer and then
on at night
uh at night i would go to the coroner's
office and i was studying to be an
investigator so i didn't have to get my
hands
dirty per se do an autopsy i'd just be
an investigator and go to
investigate you know death and then
i got i got the call and would come try
out for porn
and that was it that was amazing that's
so cool
my first cousin uh on my mom's side
is the same story right there like he
was a super goth
like trench coat kid and uh
and straight up became uh he went to
mortician school
i had a joke in my stand up that ah
when i was going to clown college my
cousin was going to
mortician school and our mothers were
getting hammered
uh debating whose son was a bigger loser
and i think that both my my my cousin is
still a funeral director
he loves it like uh something about
death just kind of turns him on you know
i mean he
he i remember getting a call from him
one time and he's like dude
dude you know the the on the the warning
on the soda machine
like you know it says don't tip the
machine like it's got a stick figure of
the machine falling on someone
he goes i got one
he says he was so excited that's how
that person died that person died that
that person died like that what's the uh
what's the most interesting cause of
death you came across
yes by typewriter wow how does one die
by typewriter
remember the old school if you guys are
old enough you know how they had the old
steel deck
you pop that thing up someone went under
and reached under
and there was those old big ass heavy
top right there
right there on their head just
concussion
and some bleeding internally and done
that typewriter
so when you when you cut up a body like
how does that work you cut up like the
fingers like you're a mobster or you
like gut them and take the organs out
and
why not you start with like there's like
a breathtaking
vision that's right yeah yeah
and is it is it true that like dead
bodies like dudes get boners sometimes
after they're dead
or is that did i just make that up
that's you getting a boner dude
yeah i don't know where that came i just
blacked out i don't know what happened
i remember my cousin also said there was
some
movie forget what if it was like uh but
it was like a football movie or
something and
in the movie the the guys the football
players were like laying down in the
middle of traffic oh the program yeah
the pro okay so i said all the cars
so so that became like a popular thing
for people to do at the time
like lay down the road yeah and my
cousin was just [ __ ] stoked about it
because he was like
i get to go scrape people off the author
the guy that we met in toronto for
dinner
he's so nice like i know he i mean he's
totally a nice guy
and uh i'm adding it's just crazy so
there's speculation
that the name corn has uh something to
do with
coroner like that it came from so so the
the the two things i saw was that it was
the the corner
in kern county or it was
children of the corn no no none of that
it's
[ __ ] horrible this story
all right well now we're now we're
excited that's right we're excited
and you know what else i'm excited about
this strap i wear on my right wrist
it's called a whoop band and if you
haven't heard about it it's time you did
and if you have heard about it it's time
you got one
why because it's the most effective
fitness tracker
out there it tells me everything i need
to know about my
fitness my heart rate variability my
strain
my sleep my recovery and i'm happy to
report that just yesterday
i had 92 recovery yeah
i felt great too so what is it it's a
membership
program right works with this band that
they give you
for free and it constantly monitors you
you don't even have to take it off to
charge it
because the charger fits right
over the band so boom
now i love this thing so much and i want
you to try it so here's how you do it
you go to woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
com and you use the promo code stevo
you're gonna get 15 off at checkout now
why are you going to do that
you're going to do that because you care
about your fitness
your health your well-being and your
happiness
and you also care about supporting stevo
by using the promo code stevo
whoop.com i love it never take it off i
haven't taken it off once since i put it
on
and i don't ever plan on taking it off
because i love that thing now
let's find out about corn i'll just do
it real short
me and some of my friends and beggars
from back in the day or at this party
there's two gay guys talking about how
they loved felching each other
okay and the one dude was talking that
he was felting his lover and the guy
[ __ ] all over his face he had a corn
kernel on his tongue okay got it
so that's how it came about so people
that knew the story they were there
we just go corn and be like shut up
derby oh god damn no no no
no no that's funny and that's how the
name came about but when
nobody in the band when when i joined
the band knew about the story i'm like i
told them this story like and they're
like
oh but it's such a cool name let's just
do it it was like
we named the corn and then our manager
larry was like hell no you cannot name
your band corn but no it's absolutely
not gold then we'll name it larry
i mean the whole thinking behind it was
like
it doesn't matter what you're called it
was like a punk rock thing it's like
[ __ ] we call corn who cares it doesn't i
don't need any mysterious weird [ __ ]
name we made it like that
it was cool because uh philly's like
dude you gotta write it with a backwards
arm like a little kid would write it so
i grabbed the crayon and i did it with
my left hand and that became the [ __ ]
it was done in two seconds and that's
become that iconic logo
wow and just that's how it all came
together was that
huh yeah because i mean i've been asked
when i was young was all yeah it's
dark and mysterious but i was like
[ __ ] corn is the dumbest name i've
ever
heard before [ __ ] band but that's
cool that's the charm of it's like we
didn't care
i loved that energy when we were young
we didn't give a [ __ ] about
nothing even the labels have told us
what to do we're just like [ __ ] you
i remember we did a photo shoot for spin
magazine
and the reason we made that cover they
put us in gorilla suits because when we
got there they wanted us to do some
stupid [ __ ] like we were moshing in a
mosh pit
and we're like absolutely [ __ ] not
we're not doing this and it got to the
point where we almost got in a fist
fight with spin magazine
with the people there the photographers
it almost broke into a full-on melee
there we're like
[ __ ] you we walked out and so they put
us as gorillas they superimposed our
heads and
put us on gorilla suits and it was
pretty funny but we always would get
into trouble like that always what year
would that have been
like 98 97 yeah
so yes there was good times we were just
didn't we just we did what we wanted and
we didn't care
who we pissed off or anything it was
amazing yeah dude
see you guys formed in 93 yeah
that's uh 27 years ago
yeah and we're still going still doing
it
and it's all the same all the same guys
yeah
we got our drummer uh the original
drummer left
uh 11 12 years ago so we got ray
but he's been with us that long he's
been in the band longer than david was
so
it's been the same and uh our guitar
player had left for eight years
and then he came back so he's good he
had to get his life together and
it's been amazing that's that's rad so
you hear about
like bands like say like say for example
motley crew
and you know the kind of the story is
the you know they don't get along with
each other
the only time they're ever all together
is when they're actually performing on
stage
they each have their own separate tour
buses like i guess
that there's it's it's pretty common
whenever like uh
there's a great deal of success and a
lot of money gets involved
that like things go sideways like did
you guys ever have
well not really we all got along pretty
well i mean we had we'd fight
there was times there was incidents
where we would get in fights but that's
just like we're brothers
we hang out with family [ __ ] happens but
we've been very lucky that we all really
i don't we love each other it's all good
yeah it's like
when we got downtown hanging out with
nobody it's like
i hang out with you more in my own
[ __ ] family i'll see you guys when we
go on to work and then i go home and do
that but
um we pretty much all get along really
good so it's been
definitely a blessing that rules man
that yeah that's super rules i've seen
on my tour with bands like that did they
they gotta take one guy out and this guy
can't run this guy
like [ __ ] but they got to do it for the
greater good because they all got to eat
you know
it's really right it's just how it goes
that would be miserable i wouldn't want
to be in
in that kind of situation right now
takes all the fun out of it
yeah you don't seem like the kind of guy
that you know that operates that way you
seem pretty laid back
yeah yeah way laid back i feel like uh
when when i got sober i've been sober
for 12 years now
and uh thank you and i feel like there
was
like you know whenever when meth would
come up i feel like
around math and someone's like oh yeah
like jonathan davis like had a real math
problem and
i did you know sometimes things come out
of my mouth
like that question and i think why did i
say
that happens a lot like why would i say
this
i have a favorite sponsor of this show
and it's a favorite by far it's called
hellotushy.com they make bidets
what's that it's a device that cleans
your butthole
and i'm so excited to have a
hellotushy.com
device in the main bathroom downstairs
so yes now lux and i can
both be pooping at the same time
and both blast our [ __ ]
to perfect cleanliness because that's
how it works
right you get done taking a big old
sloppy dump
you're still sitting on the pot you
twist this little knob right here
and blast yeah like a pressure cleaner
cleaning off all of the poop and then
you grab some toilet paper
just to dry it off and for the
satisfaction of knowing
that there was no poop on the toilet
paper
yeah that's why it's my favorite and
i do not ever want to take a poop
anywhere but inside my own house because
i love hellotushy.com
that much and i'm so sure you're going
to love it that much
too that here's the deal go to
hellotushy.com
slash stevo and you get 10
off your order again that's 10 off your
order if you go to hellotushy.com
stevo and god you and your butthole are
going to thank me for it
now let's talk about meth yeah tomorrow
actually tomorrow's my 22nd [ __ ] year
20 years dude dude it's insane but yeah
i used to
do hot reels like oh what are hot rails
is that where you light up the the glass
and then you snort it
but that's just pre-glass it was hot
because it was
like peanut butter nasty [ __ ] jet
fuel crank
you know what i'm talking then they
started cooking it with
[ __ ] ethanol or some [ __ ] and then
that glass came around
and i got out right when glass started
kicking because you could do that and
you would be up for three days off one
line
that crazy [ __ ] but ugh it makes me sick
just thinking about that [ __ ]
oh dude when i think about drugs i get
like i mean i just
[ __ ] love drugs man like i mean i
can't do them i love
that drug right there just when you did
it the initial
[ __ ] burn and all that [ __ ] and that
nasty [ __ ] that would leak out your body
that's what makes me sick but
i ain't gonna lie i loved it you feel
like you're [ __ ] superman
yeah do anything yeah it was amazing i
loved drink i loved
partying i loved all that [ __ ] but did
that all start before corn was blowing
up or was that something
that came out blew up so you were
embalming bodies doing meth
tuesday night in bakery in bakersfield
[ __ ] no
no no no i started doing meth when i was
when i moved to huntington beach
and there's a lot of meth there for
bakersfield and our uh
i got hooked up with someone that was
giving me tons of it there so
um like on the first album we have a
title called helmet in the bush
it's about mess that's what happens
so i started doing method that was the
first record and then i got sober
right after we did the third record so i
stopped meth when we started touring
because i couldn't
function there's no way i could be up
for two days and tour and
keep it together and i had to stop so
the day we took off
onto our first tour with house of pain
and biohazard we got in our trailer
and i we built bunks and i just written
that bunk and i slept for five [ __ ]
days
got up and played a show and that's when
i kicked it wow rad man
so you never toured while you're doing
meth like uh
no that it was impossible i couldn't do
meth and [ __ ] tour
i just it wouldn't work so i started
drinking and then i became a raging
alcoholic
and and cocaine occasionally when i
could find it but
yeah just they go hand in hand sure so
when you're doing meth or or you know
even with cocaine and
did you have like cool psychosis where
you're hearing voices and hallucinating
and stuff
i was always smart enough to know when
to put it down
when i start thinking i start getting
paranoid or weird i would
just i'd go to bed but i saw a lot of
people
do that [ __ ] one of my meth dealers i
went to his house and he had holes on
the walls where he's like
there's there's cameras in the walls man
and then i start talking to people like
they're following me in helicopters and
i could see the agents in the bushes
it's like oh my god you need to go to
sleep
um i never got the weird crazy psychosis
but
i met a lot of people that did and that
was when it gets scary oh yeah
i love psychosis man i i just
yeah i just had it i wanted you know and
that's why
when i think back on on drugs and like
that's what i missed i miss watching the
people walk around
you know my apartment who weren't
actually there
um so so here here's an interesting
thing i think
you know being a couple guys who have
been at it for for a considerable amount
of time
i noticed that now you know i'm uh
[ __ ] yeah i'm in the back end of my
40s over here
like jackass came out just about 20
years ago now
and it's been that long it was october
2000 when it first came out
and i you know not necessarily i don't
know i'm not interacting with as many
people now but over like say the last
few years
it just it strikes me how like
little kids you know little kids will be
excited to see me
you know like just like i feel like
matthew mcconaughey and daison confused
you know
i get older they just stay the same
i told my age i was doing this with you
and they're like that's right steve i go
wow how the [ __ ]
yeah i got the kids younger yeah they
stay the same age and then
corn shows people would think there was
a lot of older people because we were
older or bad but there's just kid
there's still kids there
right what freaked me out is the fans
that were uh
coming to our shows in the 90s and [ __ ]
now have kids and those kids are coming
to the show so
it's kind of a crazy it's it's weird i
i know what you're talking about yeah so
you have the same experience huh
yeah definitely yeah it's cool man you
always want kids around that they know
what they're sure
they have you know what the youth yeah
you're doing something right
how old are your kids i have a 24 year
old 24
13 and 15. oh boys cool man i think
maybe maybe
because i become pretty active on
youtube i think that got me in with uh
a lot of kids they know they love they
watch the old jackass stuff and then
they watch
they they watch everything it's hard to
keep up with those little [ __ ] super
rad so
what uh like like the big festivals
there were there what was that we saw
something that with the download
festival and you
you were going over in england to play
the download festival and then
you had like some crazy like medical
condition when you were bleeding
the platelets or local heads that was
called itp
i got that [ __ ] from taking an
antibiotic called cathlex
that [ __ ] it at the time they're like no
no no it's not catholics but if you go
on our website now you'll see it on the
fine print
may in rare cases cause idp so i took
this stuff
a doctor gave me and i was on the
antibiotic and all of a sudden i started
going to i went to europe to go on tour
and started seeing bruises pop up on my
body well what the [ __ ] i'm so
i'm whatever okay i got bruises i go
crazy on stage it's fine
next thing i know i go i think it was a
show in germany and i go to go to the
bathroom and i start pouring blood out
of my ass it's like
pouring out of my ass so i'm like holy
[ __ ] so
of course i'm like nothing's wrong with
me i go play a show i go back after that
pouring blood i call a doctor i'm like
what the flying [ __ ] is going on
once you go to the doctor get on this
boat we were going from germany to
london so i got on a boat
i slept went on the boat i got there
went to the doctor and he started
examining me and he's like oh this is
[ __ ] horrible bro
he put a speculum in my ass bro okay
like i'm like he's on this is gonna be
uncomfortable i'm sorry but i gotta do
this so he sticks a step boom in the ass
and he looks up and there goes yep
you're bleeding
i'm like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
just ask next time
the speculum is like the duck bill kind
of thing right so you can
ask oh my god what the [ __ ] i'm a
[ __ ] european
oh my god yeah and he went here he makes
you go back to the hotel
and he goes i'll call you let you know
what's going on and he calls me a little
later he goes
go directly to the hospital don't bump
anything
get there now so i'm freaking the [ __ ]
out i'm like what you said your platelet
counts five
you have no platelets and those are
basically what keep your blood in your
veins and
basically the what your blood is so
i go there they they take tests my
platelet counts five
they're all tripping out they give me a
bone marrow test which
was hell um and then they put me on
steroids how does a bone marrow test
work
they nail a [ __ ] spike into your hip
and suck the bone marrow out
wow that was horrible but anyways they
started putting they put me on this they
said you have this thing called itp your
immune systems killing your platelets
i'm like oh this is great
so they get my platelet count up to over
a hundred i was there
in the hospital for three or four days
and then i fly back
home and it took a year for it to
normalize but
every so often my platelet account would
go up it would be good it would be good
it'd be good and once i got off the
medicine
it normalized so i don't have it anymore
but it was scary because i
i could have let out geez maybe in my
head and doing those shows
i could have [ __ ] stroked out so
easily what's a normal platelet click
count
anywhere above 100 and what is it
a hundred and eighty and above
uh 180 to like four hundred
the pin yeah way more than five
yeah the thing we saw said that you were
bleeding out of your gums
like your gums are just pouring blood um
my gums would bleed
um anything if i pinched myself like
this just a little pinch
a bruise would come up there's no they
help line the walls of your
of your veins i guess they told me and
you just bleed it's crazy so i was just
like
taking it easy and letting the music let
the medicine work and it worked good it
took me a year to get back to normal but
did you have to cancel it
did you have to cancel a bunch of dates
um yeah we had to cancel the tour i had
to fly back and find out what was going
on
and yeah that was scary um but
it got better and better as time went on
and i won't ever take that stuff again
and that was that happened when you were
on your way to london
to play the download festival yes and so
uh and then i told the guys i'm like you
gotta go play this just get the [ __ ]
singers there to mouth through the words
at least try because in europe if you
don't show up they get pissed
they're just how that's how that i'm
dying in the [ __ ] hospital they don't
give a [ __ ]
so like um a bunch of singers all the
bands were there they all pitched in and
they
i think they did a six song set and got
through it and then bounced home
that's cool i was there for three or
four days
and then i got to go home and i
recovered pretty quickly and was back on
tour within six seven months
yeah nice the download festival's big
man do you know who the headliner was
watch it was corn [ __ ]
it was it was us or someone at that time
yeah i think it was no i remember i i i
went to the downward festival one time
to perform and i mean of course it's
like
the biggest [ __ ] stadium show you
could possibly imagine you know
like but then then they had like a side
tent which is kind of like the b stage
and in the side tent
it the it was like standing room only
and 5 000 people so the side tent was no
joke either
i did i did a like a stunt set on the
[ __ ] side tent and i had this
crazy manager at the time and he [ __ ]
says
someone gave us like hundreds
of crates of eggs just like [ __ ]
there was like thousands of eggs and
it's like i'm like
we wanna say i don't know like i don't
know how where they came from or what
but but we came up with this [ __ ]
stupid idea right
that when i finished my set i said to
the whole [ __ ] 5 000 people in the
tent
i go all right we're gonna give out
these [ __ ] crates of eggs
to the whole audience all of you and
whoever the next band is that comes out
on stage
just [ __ ] let them have it
we didn't even know who the next band
was and i can just imagine how offended
you are by this story i mean it was a
[ __ ] terrible
offensive [ __ ] idea we just did it so
but when life gives you lemons
well this is the next band that came out
was uh
the [ __ ] they were called the electric
six right and they would wear these
these [ __ ] suits they were they were
wearing like
like suit and tie kind of deal you know
and they come out
sure enough they walk out and it's just
a hail storm of [ __ ] eggs coming
through the crowd
and they're just playing like to their
credit they're going ahead and playing
getting pelted they're slipping around
on the stage it's all eggs
and like and and then the [ __ ] the
band
after the electric six was pennywise can
you imagine
how dead we would have been if [ __ ]
we got pennywise eggs
i mean they don't miss her you would get
[ __ ] up
she played with them before back in the
day before her son no one know what to
do with this so we used to do gigs with
pennywise
yeah you don't you don't [ __ ] with them
you don't [ __ ] with them no
and so i had this so now and then it was
like there was like all this trailers in
the back it was like the artist area
and i was sitting there after the show
with this with this chick who i was
right and this guy from the electric six
comes up and he's like
what the [ __ ] was that what'd you do and
he [ __ ]
like throws his beer on me but he
doesn't really get it on me he gets the
beer on the chick i'm sitting next to
you
and i'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
just attacked a girl dude
so i go and i go tell chris pontius my
jacket is buddy chris mine's like dude
this [ __ ] guy just threw beer on my
girl
and bonnie's body just looks at me like
all dead serious he goes
all right you're not lying are you right
are you telling me the truth
and i'm like [ __ ] yeah he goes all right
that's it he changes into a wrestling
singlet and goes over goes over to the
electric six trailer
and to [ __ ] fight oh he says i want
to fight all six of you
meanwhile there's not six of them
they're just called the elections
i want to fight also and this guy like
opens up a little blind to like look out
who's out there
and right when he opens up the blind
pontias [ __ ]
punches through the glass trying to
punch the guy he's all
[ __ ] bleeding everywhere they're
[ __ ] like
it was incentive what year was this that
would have been definitely
2000 2004
or 2003. either two thousand rider died
dude
yeah it actually was 2004. it was it was
spring of 2004.
or summer of 2004. anyway dude i don't
bring on [ __ ]
huge talent like jonathan davis for me
to talk the whole [ __ ] time
i'm sure he's got stories like that yeah
what are the crazier crowds you've ever
seen how was
yeah paul's been wanting to ask you
about woodstock yeah you had woodstock
99 which i know was kind of like
infamously sort of a [ __ ] show no not
our day okay
our day was amazing um we went on and it
was an amazing show the first show was
was like it's one of the highlights of
my whole career
i've never seen that many people and
everybody was having a good time
and there was no [ __ ] going on that
night it just got
progressively worse because
the the situation out there water was 10
bucks the outhouses were overfilling and
[ __ ] pisses everywhere
um it got really really bad out there so
i understand why everybody got pissed
and started rioting it wasn't
a good setup but for our
our night was amazing i remember flying
over there we all rented a jet we got
this big
it was a 737 it was us biscuit
and and ice cube and we all got on this
plane and we all rolled all to woodstock
that was fun the party on that thing was
ridiculous there was like the crew and
everybody in the back there was this
midsection which cube had and we're all
playing craps in there
and it was all there and then there was
the front section which is my section
because i like it
cool and just chill so i'd walk back
there play some crafts and walk
up to the front where i could just relax
and there was no craziness going on but
i mean that
show was man it was nuts there's
so many people and i'll never forget
that show
and you were you were like a year sober
then right
yeah and i'd been i think a year
99 yeah i was a year sober and i was
still i didn't know i was going through
dts
i was still going
have anxiety attacks and all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] um in my bunk
that whole process i didn't know that
you go through this stuff so i thought i
was just going crazy
but i got in there and i did it and i
went back and i couldn't even move
because we'd been in the studio working
on a record
we even played songs at that show that
had no lyrics i was freestyling just
mumbling
some of the songs it was it was great
but after that i went back and i
they had to carry me back in the
dressing room and i just i was dying
i was in pain i hadn't moved like that
in years and
it was it was rad then the next day we
got on plane went home it was a good
time
that's cool yeah yeah amazing i i'm the
guys are going to make fun of me but
like i've been obsessed with like
near-death experiences for a long time
and i read that when you were five years
old you had an asthma attack and you
actually died i got close to it you got
close to it you didn't go to the other
side you didn't there's no experience
no no no but that's happened me a lot
i've had a lot of near-death experiences
i wasn't out there just like it was just
like because i had asthma so bad they'd
sit me and they'd just tell my parents
if we get him through the night he has a
chance
um a lot of stuff like that i grew up in
[ __ ] tents
they would stick you in a tent over your
bed and you'd lay there and
they gave you this [ __ ] horrible drug
called quebron which is like
cocaine and alcohol i wanted that drug
when i was a kid
how old were you when he even got that i
was i died
i had horrible asthma started when i was
three years old so around being four
five six years old that was like the old
drug they gave you and
the only thing to open up your airways
is like epic epinephrine and stuff like
that so
it was drugs like that that would help
me breathe
and um yeah man it was that's
that time sucked i remember i'd have to
get blood
gases you know the little thing they put
on your finger when you go in yeah they
check how much oxygen you have in your
well back in the 70s they didn't have
that [ __ ] so what they did when i was a
little kid they'd stick a needle in your
[ __ ] leg right
next to your nuts and pull blood from
your femoral artery
so they can tell how much oxygen was in
your blood oh that [ __ ]
was traumatic now they when they do them
they do them in your wrists when you're
older but
it was [ __ ] that's a bad time that was
i was sick
a lot then so did the asthma somehow go
away because i'm picturing you going
crazy on stage like having trouble
breathing would be
yeah i mean i grew out of it i still
have it i'm on meds for it still
um but it's not like it was this i can
breathe it's fine and i have a big
oxygen tank on stage
um i hit all the time um that gets me
going
i get high off oxygen it's really cool
that's great
so like uh you won the travel round with
oxygen
i would say well yeah this corona virus
is such a
like uh it's a crazy thing you got to
wear the masks and i feel like the masks
it's like so uncomfortable
so i i was asking my buddy dr drew what
if i get like one of those oxygen tanks
where you see people wheeling it around
with them
and just do that so that i can have that
mask on
yeah and he said it's bad to have pure
oxygen all the time all day
yeah you can't have that that'll [ __ ]
you out but i do it for
what is it for the hour and a half we
play i'm pounding i'll go through a
whole tank
right and i use that the kind that they
did it's pressurized so
it's big huge hits oxygen i want some
yeah wow so did you ever smoke
like when i got yeah i started smoking
when i was some in high school did i
quit
and then when i got into corn i smoked
for a while then i quit again
for 11 years and then i smoked again for
three or four years and i
haven't smoked for five or six years
yeah it's been on and off
[ __ ] cigarettes man yeah they're
horrible i hate it i'm just doing it
because i was
bored i wanted to do something i can't
drink i can't do anything so almost
smoke
but yeah no
um so do you have a tour i mean you
can't tour and you got a new album
you know what i'm sitting here watching
paint
anything you're watching paint dry yeah
i mean
2021 do you guys have an uh dates in
mind yeah
we've got dates lined up we're gonna do
the festival run in europe
if that that can happen and then we'll
probably do a summer tour we're
switching our dates this year to next
year hopefully that'll happen
um i'm hoping and praying that that
happens if not we'll
just figure out we're gonna do um but
right now we're just sitting
and hanging out i mean i'm having i mean
i'm making the best of it
uh i'm hanging out with my kids playing
a lot of video games
and doing things that i don't usually
get to do because i'm always gone so
that has helped a lot to be able to hang
out with my boys
because i'm never home it sucks so
that's been fun
and i'm just doing stuff like this ah
dude i love it man
we appreciate it so much i feel good
what uh like i think of it like i was a
big motley crew fan
you know like growing up i had this
crazy story
where uh you know they came to my town
and and uh i called every hotel on the
yellow pages asking for a room by the
name of their manager
and and i got through to their you know
manager's brother he picked up the phone
in the room and he gave me backstage
passes so
i i met them on uh girls girls girls
tour in 1987 backstage got my picture
though i'm just a little kid
and uh like i just there's a
really big you know a big empowering
moment for me where i was like dude i
made this happen you know i can do
anything you know
and um like looking at motley crue over
the years i've seen like you know
they did tours with uh with aerosmith
and that was a big deal i've seen them
like you know
pictures with that like you know all the
rolling stones i don't know if they ever
did a show with the rolling stones but
did you ever get to perform with just
like people
that you were like it's just star struck
you're like oh my god i can't believe i
just did a [ __ ] show with mick jagger
or something like that
i did a show when we did the unplugged
on mtv we did an unplugged uh thing i
got to play with the cure
so we did a mashup of in between days
and make me bad and that was one of
those moments for me
yeah to hang out with all of them um one
time was in london i was hanging out a
bar
and i look over and it's summer lebanon
from duran duran and that was another
band i analyzed
i went up to him and i introduced myself
and we ended up hanging out all night
he went to one of my shows when i came
back that was
one of those those moments um a lot
hanging out with ozzy yeah wow
uh that still trips me out to this day
that i
sit and talk to ozzy and trapping them
all the time i mean just
heroes man jimmy page i need my kid
zeppelin i got he
he signed something for me yeah
that's epic there's been a ton of those
experiences i love
being able to meet my heroes and when
they're really cool it just makes it
better
for sure we saw something uh
uh that said that your first musical
inspiration was uh andrew lloyd webber's
superstar yeah and your favorite band
duran duran
yeah they're my favorite band i'm all
over the place bro but i was like a
neuromanic kid that's that
in the 80s that was my thing and uh
dude no excuses for that i think that
broad musical interests are important
i think that even played well into corn
i was listening to your new album you
hear
you go into some of these very melodic
lyrical moments that that
you can kind of hear that influence oh
totally man that's my i love
i love that [ __ ] that's me it just
worked because i didn't listen to metal
music until
the album that turned me on the metal
was vulgar display of power by pantera
and i was like
what is this um me back when i was a
teenager i listened to like
freestyle new york freestyle music like
stevie b
and noel and stuff like that like now
it's roller skate music but
um i love that scene and i was in the
total dj scene i didn't listen to
i was like normatic and then i went into
that like disco stuff
and then i got into industrial music but
never really listened to it
and then i got turned on pantera then i
started listening to more stuff then i
got in corn right after that so i had no
idea what the [ __ ] i was doing
at all and that was the ticket how long
did it take you to learn the bagpipes
yes i always thought that would be
pretty cool to learn how to do those it
took me a year
yeah you got to start on this thing
called a practice channel and you start
learning songs on a practice channel it
looks like a
[ __ ] really fancy flutophone and then
uh you start on the backpipes and you
start with
just the chanter which is which makes
the the the melody
and you plug up the drones and you learn
to do that and keep the air you learn
circular breathe uh not circular breathe
there's a valve on it so you just gotta
learn how to keep the bag the pressure
correctly
and then you move up you get one drone
and then two drones and three you work
your way up but it's a hard instrument
to learn that wow it's one constant tone
so you got to use grace notes to
articulate the
music and uh it's [ __ ]
at the next corn show you should
separate the crowd play the bagpipes and
just have them [ __ ] run after each
other
i'm gonna do that for you bro please
don't
yeah but please don't do that remember
let me ask you what are
what like what are we promoting we want
you we want everyone to buy
your your album right now last year the
album
uh the nothing and we just did a cover
of
uh charlie daniels devil went down to
georgia which is on
band camp and um
we're donating all the proceeds to this
wonderful school called awaken youth
which takes in kids that have lost a
parent
and are going through a hard time they
take a men teach them
you know social school everything
they're just an amazing amazing
organization
my guitar player had um sent his
daughter there
and she is a totally completely
different person
and she was working there now doing
amazing things
um and it was just near and dear to my
heart that we would
would help her you know because a lot of
kids that can't afford stuff like that
need it
so they can get the money will go go
towards giving those kids scholarships
and helping the school
out so that's what we wanted to do and
the platform to get that song is
always on bandcamp it's on bandcamp okay
corn band camp and you can just donate
whatever you can
and let's get that school some money so
they can help some kids
that's i mean the big thing for me is
helping kids um
and i love doing that right on man i'm
glad i asked you that yeah
super rad um you're a huge fan of david
lynch
oh yeah are you do you by chance uh do
transcendental meditation
oh no because we went to the uh i i i
learned it at the david lynch foundation
so i was just curious really if you
meditated
i love his movies i loved my one of my
favorite movies was dune
um and i know it makes me a sci-fi nerd
but
and i love i mean all these movies are
amazing so um
wild at heart was my david lynch movie
oh that's such a good [ __ ]
all his movies are just in there you
just don't know what the hell is going
on but i like that
i really love the news so you have a big
witch fan
oh yeah man well dude i just can't thank
you enough for doing this dude i'm going
to
tell everybody again right now to get
your ass on over to band camp and help
some kids by
purchasing devil went down to georgia by
corn
yes all right yeah [ __ ] yeah man
is he not the coolest dude ever i mean
[ __ ] if that podcast didn't put you in a
great mood
then you're just a crappy person okay i
happen to be in a fantastic mood
so for the people watching on youtube
i'm gonna show you something right now i
need to film it anyway
it's these new scars that i have on my
legs
right because this project we were
filming for i'll tell you it's the
bucket list
uh i went sprinting running the moment
that i had anesthesia injected into my
spinal cavity
which rendered the lower half of my body
completely paralyzed
and after i collapsed while sprinting
uh and i laid there paralyzed they shot
paintballs
point blank it was like shooting a
[ __ ] corpse man
and uh it didn't look like anything at
the time but
clearly paintballs are no joke we
smeared tattoo ink over the wounds
but nothing really took got a little bit
of ink in there
on one but one two three
four five six seven largely no ink
so we're just picking up this shot so
that we have it
does it all look good all right great
well street team you know what to do
i love you guys and thank you please let
jonathan davis know how much i love him
and how much you enjoyed this podcast
thanks guys